you ready yeah see the spider-man far
from home extended con complete with new
scenes and action sequences hey
everybody it's Charlie Sony re-released
spider-man far from home in theaters
with an extended cut a bunch of deleted
scenes
I watched it so that you guys don't have
to so this is gonna be my breakdown of
those deleted scenes we're doing a new
round of that Disney Plus streaming
service giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best Marvel phase 4 theory on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this so everybody heard that Sony was
releasing an extended cut of spider-man
4 from home in theaters it was supposed
to be a completely different spider-man
movie experience completely changed the
film turns out that means that they
added about four or five minutes worth
of footage mostly towards the beginning
of the film so I was actually able to go
see this and then leave the theater
because it's not a brand new post-credit
scene like they did for avengers endgame
with a whole bunch of stuff tacked on to
the end of the film with that brand-new
hulk post-credit scene the Stan Lee
cameo post-credit scene then the
spider-man far from home post-credit
scene but the brand new spider-man far
from home deleted scenes start at
Midtown high where Peter sits down with
Ned in his classroom with all those
Ironman pictures behind them when MJ
walks up and they have that funny
awkward moment he talks about his plan
to give her the Black Dahlia necklace
then the new footage starts with them
walking out into the hallway slowly
towards the door as Peter talks about
his quote unquote to-do list that he's
got to do before they travel to Europe
first thing is taking down the Manfredi
crime family nedley's asks if he needs a
guy in the chair to help Peter says he's
got it no worries I could take care of
this myself
cut to him running to the post office
where Peters stuck in this super long
line that you actually saw in the
trailer it's not moving
he needs to renew his passport he looks
around to make sure no one is watching
him that whips his phone out presses a
special button on it it activates the
spider bot drone that Iron Man made for
him that was on the old stark tech suit
while no one is looking the drone creeps
under the partition then activates the
button that turns on that kiosk the post
office worker that was working it was on
their lunch break and seems surprised
when Peter walks up because their kiosk
is open hi I'm here to renew my passport
you notice that except for his birthdate
year his actual birthday is meant to be
an easter egg for the first appearance
of spider-man in the comics the reason
why they obscured this and all the
previous trailers because it was
actually a version of this scene in the
very first spider-man far from home
trailer is just because they didn't want
to throw people off and give away the
2023 Avengers end game ending because
this first trailer where they showed his
passport came out way before endgame
ever hit theaters then Acosta was seen
at mr. Del Mar's new bodega with Petyr
picking up supplies mr. Del Mar asks you
planning a trip Peter says yes I'm going
to Europe on a class trip mr. Del Mar
says can I come too then Peter tries to
give him the most Science Bros explainer
to throw him up he says it's a science
trip the history of science Tesla da
Vinci and all that mr. Delamar says okay
fine fine fine I'm good I don't want to
go then Peter tries to impress him by
miming Spanish asking for a dual
headphone adapter mr. Del Mar makes fun
of his Spanish a little bit and says
okay fine here you go Spanish needs a
little bit of work though then there's a
scene of peter going to a pawn shop
he plunks down this giant shoebox
stuffed with 80s action figures he-man
Thundercats in a bunch of Star Wars
classic toys probably actually worth
some decent money
the clerk seems surprised looks at the
toys looks at him says you sure you want
to sell this stuff all these vintage
toys Peter says he's trying to do it to
get money to buy something really nice
for the girl that he likes the shop
owner jokes and says well I hope she's
worth it then starts taking the toys
away Peter freaks out briefly in yoinks
back the Lobot action figure from Star
Wars Empire Strikes Back from Cloud City
and says actually can I keep the Lobot
because apparently that figures really
precious to him Kevin Feige explained
that they actually had to tell Tom
Holland who Lobot was when they were
filming this scene because he was
actually there for the filming of that
Tom Hollands like well what are all
these Star Wars toys because if you can
believe it Tom Holland has actually not
seen the original Star Wars trilogy I
don't know I didn't carbon-date image on
the young side in Captain America Civil
War Peter Parker at one point it says
quote unquote that that old movie Empire
Strikes Back had you've seen Empire
Strikes Back what is your relationship
with that film
I haven't seen the empire strike I'm not
a huge Star Wars fan I'm a huge fan of
the new ones
I thought rogue one and the rise of over
the force awakens' force awakens I
thought that was dope I really am a fan
of those I thought they were great fun
but I just for some reason skipped the
original Star Wars I don't know why and
I'm very embarrassed to say it was
before your time but I should watch them
I see then did you see the prequels did
you see I did even more embarrassed to
say that I loved those movies but how
does it hit everyone what you like those
movies but I thought they were great
so you've seen one through three but not
four through six yeah yeah see this is
why we don't trust your generation you
know I mean we're a terrible generation
I need to watch the the original three
I'm gonna check back with you next
interview I'm washed alright probably
not dude I'm so busy I have no time I
try to watch a movie last night and I
fell asleep within ten minutes so he had
no idea who Lando no idea what happened
on Cloud City with Darth Vader with Han
Solo the Carbonite Kevin Feige the
director all the other people on the set
who were a little bit older and could
remember those films coming out in
theaters had to explain to him who all
those characters were so it's just a
funny moment behind the scenes and a
funny moment in this scene if you really
wanted to get high-minded about it you
could say the Lobot figure reminded him
of Iron Man because he's sort of the
integration of biology and technology in
the same way that Ironman innovates with
his nanobots then it's mash cuts to the
deleted scene of spider-man in the
upscale restaurant fighting the Manfredi
crime family it is actually probably one
of the biggest action scenes that they
had to cut it was fully finished so I
can understand why they would want to
put that back in because they spent tons
of money with a special-effects in the
visual effects on this it takes a ton of
time even for very short scenes so it's
really hard when they actually had to
cut this stuff at the last minute
because if it looks so good and it's
really cool why would you want to cut it
spider-man is jumping around in the iron
spider suit webbing everyone up they
upgraded the iron spider suit over the
last time you saw it during Avengers
infinity war it does way more stuff they
made it more dynamic they said they just
wanted to show it off from a different
perspective than what you've seen before
like in the months that they had been
blipped back because it hasn't been that
long since the end of Avengers endgame
Peter has had more time to figure out
all the special abilities that the irons
suit has so he's using it in a much more
sophisticated way than he used it during
Avengers infinity war when that was
mostly instinctive but this is probably
the most classic spider-man you'll see
him jumping around wall clipping
spider-man comic book style taking these
criminals down like it's no big deal
just bric-a-brac just another day in the
trenches taking down these nobody
criminals even though technically the
Manfredi crime family is a pretty big
comic book easter egg they didn't say
anything about Silvio Manfredi during
this scene but he is so badass in this
small enclosed space that it does make
you really excited even with all the
spider-man drama between Marvel and Sony
to see them do more with spider-man
action scenes like this in future
spider-man appearances whether they be
in venom movies in Sony spider-man solo
films like spider-man 3 or when he
eventually comes back to the MCU one of
the best things that Marvel has done
with the spider-man character in
spider-man homecoming spider-man far
from home in the Avengers films is
nailed the physics of spider-man in a
way that they have not done in previous
films and that's a little bit of their
filmmaking technique but also the
technology that they use for visual
effects getting that much better in the
last couple of years nowhere is that
more evident that when you go back and
you rewatch the Tobey Maguire spider-man
films precious as they are but you watch
the web slinging scenes with Mary Jane
and you can definitely tell that she's
holding on to a mannequin not an actual
person and her hair is even blowing the
wrong way during this
[Music]
[Applause]
you
still love those classic tobey maguire
spider-man films but from a
technological filmmaking perspective
things have just gotten so much better
with the marvel spider-man movies while
they's finishing taking down each of the
man Freddy's one of them whips out a
submachine gun it just goes to town on
him and he acts like he's just eating
all the bullets just full-on he's not
even trying to dodge them he falls
behind this giant table acts like he's
dying oh no you finally got me then
quick moment later stands up and says up
just kidding is bulletproof you can't
hurt me with that he continues taking
the rest of them down says let's keep it
moving guys I got a lot to do today I'm
giving this place 1 star because they
are inside a restaurant while this is
all happening a bunch of the mobsters
bum-rush him in the iron spider legs
kick into overdrive remember how I said
they wanted to upgrade the iron spider
suit over what you saw from it during
Avengers infinity war one of the ways
they did that was by making the iron
spider legs way more active as if they
were an extension of Peter like he
actually had eight spider arms they
didn't fully explain the neural
interface between Peter in the actual
suit but he does have a mental link with
it so he doesn't need to speak when he
wants it to do things he just thinks
like Black Panther thinks make the
helmet go on and all of a sudden Black
Panthers helmet comes on it's the exact
same situation with Iron Man's nano BOTS
armor and Peter's iron spider suit
because that's all based on Iron Man
suits he makes one last quip as he takes
them all down and says I'm definitely
not giving you a 20% tip the cops arrive
and then he has that funny scene where
he jokes about doing their job for him
just kidding you guys are awesome but
now you guys got to really step it up
because I'm going on vacation and then
it cuts to him actually getting on the
plane and then going to the vacation
like I said though that was really only
four to five minutes at the very
beginning of the film there wasn't a
brand new post-credit scene like a lot
of us wondered because Sony obviously
wanted to re-release this just because
Marvel re-released Avengers end game and
it did relatively well for them it got
him over that hump but the reason why
they released it wasn't the same reason
why Marvel re-released Avengers end game
that was because they were within a
couple million dollars of beating
avatars worldwide box office and they
just wanted to jump over that last
little hurdle a lot of people
understandably gave him some [ __ ] for
that so no worries if you didn't feel
like spending the extra money just to
see this extra couple minutes worth of
footage
be too bummed out about spider-man the
MCU because eventually Sony and Marvel
will come back to the table everybody
involved believes that eventually long
term they will work out a new deal but
it'll take a little while for that to
happen so I will do update videos if
they release big news about what's going
on between them the embargo is up on the
Joker movie so I'm allowed to post my
early non-spoilery review that will post
tomorrow there's also a brand new
birds-of-prey trailer that just released
in theaters so we'll do a video for that
and there's a whole bunch of other
Marvel stuff coming up leave your video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the ultimate masters
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of that Fantastic Four Comic Con teaser
new x-men new Wolverine and click here
for all my videos about what's going on
with spider-man leaving the MCU thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]